Laughter is a social emotion,
so we're 30 times
more likely to laugh
if there is somebody else with
us than if we're on our own.
And we'll laugh more
if we know those people,
and we'll laugh more
if we like those people.
Why do humans laugh?
We laugh to show that we agree
with what someone said.
That we remember the same
thing that they're alluding to.
People will also use laughter
to try and mask other emotions.
People will laugh to try
and pretend they're not upset
or to cover up being angry
or embarrassed or in pain.
People will use laughter
to get other people to do things.
If you get someone laughing,
they will tell you more intimate
details about themselves.
There are two main kinds
of laughter, according to Sophie.
The first is sort of
spontaneous laughter,
if you think about laughter
that happens
and you cannot stop laughing,
it can sound like this:
The laughter just overwhelms you
and then you're just going
to have to ride it out.
That's quite a different kind
of laughter
from the sort of laughter
you find in conversations,
which is of course most
of the laughter you encounter,
and that sounds more like this.
There laughter is really brief
and it's shared,
people tend to laugh together,
and they laugh together
in a very coordinated way.
People laugh at the ends
of sentences.
And that's actually
quite interesting,
because it's even the case
if somebody's having a sign
language conversation
where they could laugh
all the way through,
they don’t, they still laugh together
at the ends of sentences.
So why can laughter
sometimes feel contagious?
You can probably think of occasions
when you've been watching television
or listening to the radio,
maybe it's been broadcast live,
and the presenter or presenters
start to get the giggles.
The award-winning screenwriter, Abby
Mann, has died at the age of 80.
He won an Academy Award in 1961
for Judgement at Nuremberg.
Ab-- Excuse me, sorry.
Abby Mann also won
several Emmys, including--
Including one in 1973 for--
For a film which featured a--
(giggling)
A police detective called--
(laughter)
If you chuckled while listening
to that clip, here's why.
It's called behaviourally
contagious phenomena,
which are things you can catch
from somebody else
just because they're doing them.
You might have noticed
this happens with yawning,
it happens a lot with laughter.
Babies don't show any behaviourally
contagious phenomena,
and effectively we teach them to.
So if you look at babies and parents,
parents will try
and make babies laugh,
and babies do laugh
and it's lovely.
If the parent laughs,
the baby doesn't join in.
But if the baby laughs,
the parent does join in,
because the contagion is working.
And effectively that seems
to be the root
whereby we start to teach babies
that this is something
that we do together.
Laughter isn't exclusive to humans.
We know that laughter is extremely
easily observed in other apes.
So gorillas laugh, chimpanzees laugh,
orangutans laugh,
and they laugh in a very, very
similar way to humans.
The main difference is that
chimpanzees, for example,
laugh on an exhalation
and an inhalation,
so we just laugh ha-ha-ha,
breathing out,
chimpanzees do more
like a ha-ah-ha-ah,
sounds a bit like he-eh-he-eh.
So chimpanzees use laughter
in a pretty complex way
much as we do, and it happens
in the same situations.
It's associated with
tickling, with play,
with trying to make play last longer.
And it's not just primates.
Laughter-like behaviour has also been
described in rats and parrots.
Unfortunately laughter
can also have a darker side.
These big squeezes that you do with
your ribcage when you laugh,
particularly if you're laughing
really hard,
it's quite stressful for your heart
and your lungs
and that can mean if you have some
sort of problem
maybe with your heart or your lungs
or your blood vessels,
you can put them under more strain.
And throughout history
there are examples of people
who have died laughing.
And I think, if you're going
to have to go somehow,
probably going while you're laughing,
there could be worse ways.
Luckily there are lots of health
benefits to laughing too.
You are more relaxed when you laugh.
So as soon as you start laughing,
you get a reduction in adrenaline.
You also get an increased uptake
of the body's naturally
circulating endorphins.
Now that is because you do quite a
lot of exercise at your ribcage
when you laugh.
It's exactly the same
as a runner's high
or the good feeling
you get after exercising.
And interestingly
that's true of laughter
even if you've
completely faked the laughter,
so it does suggest that
it's something to do
with the ha-ha-ha movements.
So if you want to get
your endorphins going,
you can start
by laughing out loud.
And if you're by yourself
and have no one to laugh with,
here's something that might help.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Where did you find that?
What is that?
(laughing)